Charlie D'Amelio and chase Hudson are
back together okay so they're back
together on tick tock very crazy the
exes sparked reconciliation rumors
earlier this week reuniting on tick tock
nearly two months after they called it
quits on Tuesday Charlie posted this
video of herself dancing in the pool
with a surprise appearance by her ex at
the end she captioned the clip the boy
as for chase aka lil hoodie the 18 year
old posted his own video with Charlie
writing long time no see brother play
Wii TV beat while the former couple
hasn't commented on the current status
of their relationship
Charlie appeared to visit the hype house
over the weekend posting videos with a
few of the other members in May et
learned that the 16 year old and her
sister Dixie actually left the hype
house because it was turning more into a
business than a creative space and chase
and Charlie aren't the only tick tock er
sparking reconciliation rumors we are
just friends
Addison Rae and Bryce hall have been
spending lots of time together and fans
are wondering if the exes are dating
again it is crazy that I'm in that
position now that people are like so
curious about like who I like I don't
know it's so cool though not only are
they posting a ton of tic TOCs together
like this and this
got to bag but they were also spotted at
an LA protest together recently
Addison shared this shot on her
Instagram story and that right there
that's Bryce but it was his tweet on
Monday that really had people talking
the 20 year olds wrote simply Oh Addison
but quickly followed it up explaining
that Addison had tweeted the previous
message herself I don't know what's
cuter Bryce
tweeting it himself or Addison being
comfy enough to do it we actually met in
October we kind of started hanging out
more and then like once I moved here we
like started hanging out a lot and then
we got like super close and like we were
really really really good friends yeah
back in February Addison told et that
you decided to keep it friendly but they
weren't ruling out the possibility of
getting back together in the future we
were talking and like kind of on and off
just like trying to figure things out
you know things happen and then like we
just decided like we're better off as
friends for now because like we both
have like totally different I guess like
lifestyles right now so I think right
now we're just better off as friends and
like we both like mutually decided that
like it was kind of just a thing that we
were like you know we love each other so
much and like we love being around each
other and we're super good friends so
it's like for I guess for now it's just
the best that we stay that way and like
you know we support each other 100% et's
reached out to reps for Charlie chase
Addison and Bryce to find out what's
going on